on the show we've chronicled the war on
standards at the FAA we're irrelevant
biographical questions were imposed on
aspiring air-traffic controllers
sadly this is far from the only example
of standards declining in the United
States beneath public view there's never
debate on any of this it just happens
it's happening in fact in scientific
fields you wouldn't think it would but
it is and the pages of a City Journal
Heather McDonald has chronicled it in
detail how schools and other
institutions are cutting our quirements
in an effort to be more diverse whatever
that means Heather McDonald also wrote
the upcoming book the diversity delusion
and she joins us tonight Heather thank
you for coming on so we were really
stunned to find that the FAA was
intentionally trying to hire unqualified
air-traffic controllers because it's
insane and dangerous but you wouldn't
think that that same impulse would find
its way into the hard sciences into
medicine for example or research science
but you say that it is it's very
disturbing Tucker there's not a single
meritocratic institution that is free
from the poison of identity politics the
federal government is wasting tens of
millions of taxpayer dollars pressuring
scientific labs to hire by the
irrelevant criteria of race and gender
it's doing research on get this
intersectionality in the STEM fields
research conducted by two specialists in
gender identity this is not what
Congress had in mind when they created
the National Science Foundation in 1950
to sponsor serious scientific research
we're putting our scientific
competitiveness at great risk by
introducing the total irrelevance e of
of race and gender diversity into
scientific accomplishment well I'm not
confused because I thought the left
quote believed in science they had all
March announcing that I think about a
year and a half ago is there scientific
evidence that the race or gender of a
scientific researcher for example is
material that it affects the outcome of
the experiment in some way well the left
hate science when it's it's proof
facts that they don't like and then it
hates objectivity but no there is
absolutely no scientific evidence we
have had 200 grantees of the National
Science Foundation that have won Nobel
prizes things like discovering dark
matter discovering how viruses work and
this was with utter indifference color
true color blindness to true meritocracy
and there's of course they concede on
the left that diversity matters in its
scientific thinking no it doesn't if a
lab is all-female great if a lab is all
asian great if a lab is all-black great
all the public cares about is are you
working to cure Alzheimer's and the way
you do that is by being color and gender
blind and hiring on merit not on race
and gender it's it's terrifying they've
even they've infected science with
politics obviously I hope you will come
back in future days with details on all
this Heather Heather McDonald great to
see you thank you